l'alimentation c'est le coeur de la
mission de danone et donc parce que nous
voulons travailler en particulier sur
l'aspect de la reconnexion entre le
consommateur et l'alimentation
c'est important que dans notre centre de
recherche nous offrions cette même
possibilité pour nos salariés et donc
depuis quelques années on a lancé un
programme qui s'appelle caire et dont le
but est justement de tester différentes
options initiatives autour de la qualité
de vie au travail à l'intérieur de
keyria toute une partie qui s'appelle
bien dans mon assiette et dont le but
justement c'est de travailler
spécifiquement sur l'alimentation est
donc une des dernières initiatives des
dernières expériences que l'on a lancé
ses joues vrir un potager d'entreprise
donc ce potager d'entreprise il est auto
géré par un certain nombre de salariés
aujourd'hui on en a une vingtaine à peu
près qu'ils utilisent le potager et on
essaye de faire plus que simplement
cultivent un potager mais l'enfer aussi
un lieu d'expérimentation et donc à côté
du potager lui même mais on suit ceux
qui sont nos jardiniers l'entreprise
pour voir comment travailler sur ce
potager voilà sans occuper ça va aussi
changer leur rapport à l'alimentation le
lien social bref tout ce qui tourne
autour de l'alimentation et que voilà
dans un centre de recherche un endroit
idéal pour pour tester ses différentes
expériences
potager car esso rep on a énormément de
besoins chez nous un premier temps sur
le plan nutritionnel dans donnant accès
à nos salariés d'avoir une chance de
produire ce qu'eux mêmes ils vont
consommer et ça c'est tout enfin en lien
avec la mission du groupe danone
c'est une alimentation saine pour le
plus grand monde en plus le jardinage
nous permet l'amélioration de qualité de
vie en exerçant une activité en plein
air et de tisser des liens de communauté
avec les salariés provenant de services
différente aujourd'hui
le potager est composée de vingt
parcelles géré au niveau individuel ou
ambulants nous avons construit à une
communauté ou en échange de bonnes
pratiques on s'entraide à arroser et on
partage même des graines de semence à
titre personnel s'occuper du potager me
donne 10 minutes de réflexion dans la
journée le temps de respirer et de faire
travailler mes mains j'ai rencontré de
nouveaux collègues durant cette aventure
et j'ai retrouvé un peu de campagne dans
ma vie très urbaine
aujourd'hui dans la première année du
potager on constate déjà que c'est un
succès mais on a vraiment hâte de voir
d'où ça peut aller l'année prochaine